well my friends a texas woman has been
charged with murder for what authorities
are calling a self-induced abortion
this is sadly completely predictable
based on what texas has been doing as
far as abortion law for
years now and really for decades now in
terms of what they've been trying to do
and one of the lines that's repeated so
often that it's like cliche we've all
heard it so many times it's a cliche at
this point is
banning abortion
doesn't reduce abortions it just reduces
legal abortions in your particular state
what does that mean well it means if you
make abortion more difficult to obtain
or you make it illegal you make it
illegal in more situations people will
either go to a neighboring state if they
can afford it and if it's legal in a
neighboring state
or
they will pay for an illegal abortion
this is very common in other countries i
mean if you if you look at where i was
born argentina there were long periods
of time where it was illegal but if you
had money you just went to a private
doctor and it was fine and you you had
the money to do it that's the second
option third option what we sometimes
call a back alley abortion a home
abortion in this case it's being called
a self-induced abortion and that is
exactly what happened here with 20 60 or
26 year old lizelle herrera
who was arrested
late last week and has been charged with
murder herrera was given a 500
000 dollar bond
5 half a million dollars we are talking
about here now remember that this idea
of
i don't know
do we punish the women
this is something republicans have been
toying with for a long time they've
tended to go against it but remember
that when donald trump ran trump who
trump was pro-choice trump was
pro-choice for 68 years then he ran for
president as a republican and he had to
have some kind of credible escape hatch
to explain suddenly i'm against abortion
he's speaking at the march for life the
story trump told us completely
unbelievable story
was that despite being in favor of
choice for 68 years
he met a kid
whose mom said
i thought about getting an abortion and
trump was like i like that kid
it would have been sad if that kid
didn't exist so now i'm the strongest
pro-life candidate i mean it was nobody
believed it and a result of trump not
actually being pro-life was that he
stepped into some controversial
territory like when he said well you've
got to punish the woman remember this do
you believe in punishment for abortion
yes or no as a principle the answer is
that
there has to be some form of punishment
for the woman yeah it has to be some
form ten cents ten years i don't know
that i don't right so the next day trump
walked it back
but the punishment for back alley or
home abortions
that they seem fine with and we have
other instances of similar situations
you might remember back in october just
a few months ago six seven months ago uh
yeah seven months ago we covered the
story i think on the bonus show of a
native american woman in oklahoma who
was convicted of manslaughter over a
miscarriage this was brittany poula 21
years old convicted on second degree
manslaughter by a comanche county jury
for the death of her fetus with a
gestational age of 15 to 17 weeks
so don't be confused about the big
picture
of how texas
has dealt with abortion the number of
abortion clinics in texas has declined
dramatically you go back to the
mid-1980s and we're putting a chart up
on the screen for our viewers
over 120 clinics at which abortion
services were available that is now
under 20 as if a few years ago it may be
even lower now i didn't have updated
data so people
really may have no idea what we're in
for here if republicans get their way
and this is really about two things it's
actually it's really about three things
number one this is about
on paper reducing the number of
abortions in texas now remember you're
not actually reducing the number of
abortions you might reduce the number of
legal abortions in texas because people
will either be pushed to other states if
they can afford it or they will be
pushed into you know so-called private
back alley home abortions that's number
one number two this continues to be
about controlling women's bodies in a
way that lines up with the stated morals
of the people doing it and it's
important to include the way the word
stated morals because as we have found
out through the election of trump with
evangelical support
despite his affairs and all these things
we know that they are only their stated
morals it's not their morals they're
their morals that they use to try to get
themselves elected
um and then number three
it's also a real sign about what might
be coming at the supreme court level
within months the supreme court one of
the most right-wing supreme courts we've
had in decades is going to make a
decision that might change the
established precedent of roe v wade
making abortion legal in the country
generally speaking without placing an
undue burden on women that uh
framework that precedent may be reversed
in just months by the current supreme
court the states are pushing it because
this has always been the plan when they
get a more conservative supreme court
they all start doing it mississippi
texas missouri many states have been
pushing and passing similar bills
knowing that they're going to be fought
they're going to be appealed hopefully
they go to the supreme court and the
supreme court will issue what could be a
life-changing ruling for so many women
and families around the country is it
time to move out of texas well i don't
know
a part of it is a question of
what does the supreme court
decide
um and we're going to know that soon but
this is exactly what we predicted they
would do
they are doing it and you can look at
any one of these cases and say well but
in this particular case or in that
particular
this was the plan all along we knew that
they were going to do it and they're
going to continue